oh interesting
okay i'm actually gonna try to get a
kill here
oh ethan i know it looks bad but i
really just miss you
where was the body honestly bob's a
sicko i'm not
i don't even care i'm glad i never hang
out wow
bob slit my throat in the security room
i don't care anymore
was it in the security where was the
body well that was a couple of rounds
ago i never forget
never a couple of rounds the first round
no i'm talking about when bob was dead
above communications to the right of uh
electrical defense
i've been peeping with ethan we've been
that's what i'm like like glue on a
sandwich
yeah i went down and i did the little
maze thing
the the light thing that you have to
track and then i went up and
i did the switch next to the telescope
i saw you walk into the laboratory last
and that's you it seems like you would
cross paths with the body
i did see tesh and sean do the lights
with me
i will say that i did see tesh fixed it
i walked in too late and then tyler
walked in after
i just want to thank ethan for not
killing me as we hung out together for
the first time in mind and
shout out to ryan for not stabbing me
because he has the vendetta against me
so good stuff
listen to this i'm gonna skip it for now
let's hang out about jack like he could
have crossed paths with the body
okay he's a good guy that's a very big
accusation to make up just
saying i'm just saying one body i'm i'm
just saying i'm just saying i completed
one task so i've been doing my job
okay uh we got away with it well that's
great i don't know what to do next
i literally have no idea
let me just actually no this is a bad
idea why would i do that
oh weird oh weird
oh interesting someone just came out of
there
okay fascinating
it's somebody called a meeting right as
i click report
okay i was gonna say it was early on and
it literally he just had to have died so
i clicked the button because i saw it on
the vinyls
jack you're over the body yeah it's down
in the bottom right next to the
where you match up like the specimen
things is still suspicious of jack after
that
hold on did you see anything i saw tyler
come from that direction
tyler went down below um in the walkway
between the specimen and the area
because i was trying
to make sure nobody came that way from
bottom right you just saw me do the
labyrinth
in the bottom right there's no way yeah
so i was between
i was between the the doors ryan was
coming from
there's no way because i saw you going i
was making sure nobody came from ethan
so whoever was above went and got
nobody came from ethan what do you mean
we didn't even know anything was down
there i will say
ethan's the one that's dead and john
just said he was over the bottom wait
tyler i'm so surprised i don't like that
i this is all my fault i didn't stick
with ethan
what are you doing you've been you've
been quiet
at the end there wait who was
approaching us while we were in that
room
uh i don't mean communication because
that was me
okay that was you yeah i was in the
complete opposite direction of that
where was ethan's body i don't like what
tyler just said but z is also throwing
out
heavy accusations against me so oh i
just have to i just i had to vote
that's all i voted for is dead i should
have stuck with him ethan i'm sorry
damn it wade
maybe he killed him you're throwing one
like ryan ty
okay wow
i guess we'll never know we'll never
know
sorry ethan okay uh uh oh i'm
i'm like the only one left that's
fascinating wade probably came up here
damn i didn't realize there was a timer
on this
okay interesting interesting interesting
interesting interesting interesting
i think this is a thing
outside weapons where was weapons it's
the bottom middle
mark you said you were following wade
last time and this time right well so
where did you go
i went to do the thing with wade yeah
it's dead yes and
did you kill him no no maybe
he might have deserved it
but i'm gonna go with no i don't know i
don't know if he's a genius or a [ __ ]
i was actually uh up in the medical area
wherever that is top rightish wait wait
hold on
i saw i saw mark there i saw him out
there i was up there i did see him there
oh wait a second
now we've got mark confirming can i
point something
else out i've been suspicious of jack
for two rounds he was over the body last
round he reports the body
this round yeah because i'm doing my
tasks and the bodies are
everywhere hard on tyler so unless we
don't have the other guy yet
i gotta i have a question for you you
came into the little room a little bit
later you know tyler was bad
are you murdered straight to the upload
uh the the communications due to my
upload
where i left mark and wade why are you
protecting jacqueline
because i think we got the bad guy
already i think we got one of them you
know what we don't know that
i think it's right i'm voting he keeps
accusing me i don't like that
this is my defense cause i think we got
the first guy correct
yeah i think so too okay all right i
have no idea
how do i sabotage something wait how do
i
o2 right this way where is this
oh no this here yes here
he might be going for the emergency
meeting i have no idea i have no idea
what to say
see the thing is like me being an
imposter i actually have no idea what to
do
[Music]
hmm interesting do i need to be i don't
i don't know i'm very confused
oh god well that's a problem
[Laughter]
well isn't an issue
this is a problem this is big brain time
it was sean i saw him do it oh my god
i literally saw him mark was at the door
he didn't report anything and then he
came chasing after me thinking he could
kill me again but didn't realize there
was a cooldown no i was actually stuck
in the doors were locked down there are
two people dead mark there's no way mark
knew this game killed two
no i said it doesn't even matter i
literally
saw him kill him you're letting the
dumbest player get away with the
sweetest thing
you gotta remember z confirmed mark was
in the top right and z is innocent now
it's you and i've been with ryan a lot
no no no and z is screaming at the
computer right now
because he accused me so much i ran away
from my screaming
and look if i'm wrong
saw him do it i got it ryan you trust me
oh god you're the last person tonight
ryan haven't we been hanging out like so
long together
we definitely got one of them because
there's four of us oh
i hate to do this john
because he helped get the other guy so i
don't [ __ ] know at this point
oh my gosh i played so [ __ ] hard
don't you be lying to us
mark i swear to god i know he's gonna
gloat about it for days you're welcome
is this big brain uh how do i
how do i do this
[Music]
i can't believe that worked oh my god i
can't believe it
it's killing wade mark totally lied the
first round he and i weren't hanging out
together at all
and i was so confused i didn't say
anything i was like was i
mark i
that was you i didn't know man because
sean saw me
kill and we're both in this room and i'm
like oh god 30 seconds i'm never gonna
i can't believe everyone but my lies
were terrible every time
i even said i killed wayne i was like
yes
no i'm gonna go with no your lie was so
bad i believe i was like that would be
so stupid though
for sure okay all right i'm never gonna
be able to repeat that again
ever in the history forever i just lied
my entire ass off
my whole ass is gone what is this
what is this what do i do oh
well okay okay good
great great
there's wade oh that doesn't look good
reboot re
reboot what the hell is this
return in 52 oh return oh okay i'm an
idiot
okay well it's going smoothly
ah i don't trust i don't trust anybody
okay whoever is on cameras next to me i
really thought you just did the deed on
me
i thought i had a test down there but i
did not so i saw you kind of left
hello bob where was bob where was bob
i saw bob with i saw bob tyler yeah
down below he was on wires and then he
went up with me to do lights and then i
wasn't with him anymore
i feel like ethan might know where bob
was yes i walked into office
and bob's body was on the ground what is
office
yeah where is that it's right next to
the like the room that we're all
standing in the like button room or
whatever i will say
bob and tyler were doing i was looking
at the camps bob and tyler were doing
electrical together but then tyler
finished and left and then bob was still
there what if bob was the imposter and
he couldn't live with the guilt
tyler tyler what was your defense
earlier i saw bob do
elec uh electrical with me and then i
ran off and lost track of him and then
right now i'm down you're just copying
everything i just said no no
i'm down in the d i said that before you
said it i went down
there are you gaslighting me are you
putting thoughts in my head no i
definitely said it before you said it
was before ethan
i can keep an eye on tyler kill tyler
train
right now i
thoughts in your head okay somebody some
people are trying to get tyler out
where's tyler where'd he go i literally
don't know
i have no idea wait this way
i think ethan might be but i have no
idea
oh yeah we're good yeah cause ethan did
report but at the same time
he was very quiet that time
wait where am i going here oh no
chilled is gonna kill me i'm so dead
all right cool maybe not maybe i'm alive
maybe i live maybe i live what am i
looking for
align it with what oh here we go
okay where no yes
no god why's it got to be on the all the
way other side
why do i have to do this all the way
over here i don't like this this feels
bad this feels bad i don't like it i
don't like it i don't like it i'm gonna
die this is where i die this is where i
die everybody this is where i die i'm
dying
i'm dying currently i'm currently dying
dying is happening immediately now
death death is upon me death is oh
whatever the room is above weapons i
think ryan and i came out together
i was with chill chill saw me talk right
then i went down room
where where where's the weapons room
where where which side bottom middle
it's not the very bottom middle it's the
room right above that all right so i was
in specimen with
a bunch of people i saw jack there i saw
chilled there i saw tesh there
i saw ryan there someone i noticed
coming from around weapons or
communications going into the southern
portion of the office with me was
ethan i went into the office to finish
the task
that i was going to start last time the
like card flip thing that's when i found
bob's body
uh i went up to the what is it called
the node thing the rocket
thing where you press all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't believe him wait what did
you say
about chilled which was my only suspect
was top right with me he saw me go in he
stood there with me as i was doing the
test
i went out i think ryan and i exited
together i went over to the room
saw the body and reported it i know what
you're thinking mark said he was going
to be by tyler the whole time it's weird
right
jack but it wasn't me i voted for ethan
me too
the location matches over right i hope
but i hope chilled and wade aren't in it
together
i trust way too i don't trust myself
wade i think it's chilled and i think
his cooldown was running when he was
trying to get me
is the thing i'm the greatest
oh oh no
okay oh whoops oh no i'm a dead man i'm
a dead man
no i'm not yes i am
i'm a dead man i'm a dead man who walks
around
i'm a dead man
oh my all my tasks are all done
oh i found a dead body
and i saw a person
walking oh who was that where'd you find
the body
it was in the lab i was finishing my
last task which was putting a skull
a prism of some type
a leaf and a fourth object and there was
someone else there if mark was being
honest ryan was in that room as well
yeah okay was it i was doing the same
task
i saw chilled try to do a task the one
at the little
tesla coil thing where you do the maze
light and i did it but the bar didn't go
up
and then as i was running away you
chased me and then ran out of lab when i
went into it and then the lights went
off and you were gone
i'm telling you this is this is wrong i
did my tasks i didn't see sean outside
sean was running circles outside my
tasks are done oh
because if you're trying to guess like
me uh then i think it's you because
i've been doing my testing all the time
well i'm i'm always gonna blame chill to
be back
hey this is baby's meeting
clang clang i dead body
ryan well ryan was definitely in there
but if
i don't know if she was trying to play
like my dead body ryan
i dead body ryan that's my argument i
dead body ryan
i don't think it's weight either who are
we voting for i don't know
if it's ryan jack i will fully apologize
i think sean's innocent or at least he
didn't kill him
wow jesus christ okay ryan voted chilled
as well
interesting i always vote killed
i lost a little ploop as the poop is
over the people hit the law
thank god because you guys were on ryan
then you're on jack and chill and i was
my blood was boiling
like honestly i screwed up at the
beginning because the entire time i was
like i have to kill chill first
screw it chat i have to kill him
why are you guys always suspecting me
because you're a terrible liar it was
ryan and who
it was ethan ethan ethan ethan
it just made me want to vote you even
harder ethan was doing the work
because i was trying to find killed
because right after i killed tyler i was
like i should not have killed him
because everybody expected in the last
round why did i do that
i will stick by tyler i will vet him if
he kills me
uh if he ends up dead you know that's
not my problem
but if he kills me then you know oh no
tyler oh i'm
so exposed oh the
cold is really getting to me my backside
is so
ready here it is
already so dark i can't see him no don't
lose me tyler if you lose me
if you lose me i can't protect you oh
there he is got him
okay he's a good man all these up
yeah yeah i'm right here oh it's your
chance it's your chance
well since he's here i'm gonna do mine
too
oh my god this is awful there we go
there he is
tyler hmm
seems fake let's take a shower together
tyler let's really see
and we'll see the cleanness the
cleanliness
hmm
oh no i can't see him where'd he go
tyler
tyler tyler
oh where is it okay i found the body in
the office
my god jesus jesus so mark is definitely
clear because i was
that they were both there i watched them
do it at each other
okay because i just want to say
wait hold on what did you just say i
said i was just next to you
were you i think so i saw you going into
the
the middle building i think okay in the
in the office
i don't know i was having to do lights
and i thought i passed you at some point
well why were you over there right where
the body was
the body is an office the mill the
middle building is the thing
why would i just out myself if i killed
someone i just said i just saw you
inadvertently out yourself when i could
see people in the dark any time i speak
i get myself killed to add
this the only time that you would have
seen me is when i was going up to the
office because i was in uh
decontamination the whole time there was
nobody else there the building the
bottom right
i had a wired crossing test to do and i
saw you in the building i don't know
it's like bottom middle
i saw wade which body did you find there
ethan which body did you find okay i saw
wade
chilled and tesh down in the bottom left
corner i saw them all go past the camera
one way and then i saw wade and tesh
leave like the tree room i think wade is
pretty suss
i'm going for it you're hanging out with
dead people wade yeah
you're kind of i guess i'm joining them
good luck guys [ __ ] i hope you lose
all right so i have done only one task
which is fine because be a kuaz
right be a q as too slow
too slow accepted
nice i think we're gonna lose this time
i'm pretty sure
we're gonna lose i'm pretty sure the
losing is about to happen
but that's okay what the hell there we
go
uh specimen room oh yeah that's right
what a lovely day what a lovely day
full of lovely people
dwinkas easy this is fun
wait why did all my things go away
okay i just saw tyler walk out sean
don't even sean literally was chasing me
to kill me
i i'm not even near you you were
interested in you trying to shoot
twice i know it did not do it there's no
way i
did vet tyler the first time it is
definitely
sean sean you were quiet last round
awfully quiet
he switched directions to go towards
ethan because ethan and i were near each
other
most of that round no no no no come on
no it's definitely sean i'm not he was
running around in the trash area
left the door and your body is right
next to it
it is definitely information on this
neither of them has been around me very
much but i trust mark betting tyler in
the first round because there were too
many deaths for tyler to not have
participated i think wade was actually
back oh that's
true it's not jack it's tyler three
people died the first round
i was with tyler the whole time it's
sean
definitely sean but also tyler's
terrible at making his case
no literally sean chased me and i ran
away from him because he actually was
like
out of a room with closed doors what i
think happened is
tyler saw sean shawn's cool down was
running
so he self-reported to try to throw us
off
what i'm gonna go with the hurt i guess
i don't know let's see did we win
or is mark leading us to doom by vetting
the
imposter objective
[Applause]
sean you [ __ ] [ __ ]
came around the [ __ ] room and i was
so afraid
and i trusted you and then i was like
what is he doing why is he running
around
oh to kill me
he was chasing me and he went off of me
to you ethan i'm sorry i had to get away
i was
trying to run to this thing there's
nothing worse than killing somebody and
immediately passing someone walking
toward the body
wait you didn't even try and defend
yourself your lives were so
all over the place hold on but you
you passed you passed me so close to the
body though
oh yeah very close
i was still wiping off the blood from
the murder
all right it's me and wade try to follow
him try to kill people together with him
oh no please tell me it's not going to
be bob
this is weird it's awfully suspicious
oh no god damn it oh wait dude
i [ __ ] saw wade he [ __ ] killed him
and self-reported jesus christ
mark you were right there unless mark
because the door was closed and i went
over to open the door and wade was there
killed bob mark wait
hang on okay wait no no okay i i was in
the room
okay hang on let me i'm trying to
remember what the colors were
i'm trying to remember the colors i'm
not good with names i'm good with colors
okay all right all right purple was dead
right
bob that's bob okay all right who was
closer
uh listen guys i killed bob i did it
right then and there
he looked at me okay this is this is
what
wade wayne and i
ethan you saw the gun in bob's pocket i
had to do it
wade why do you [ __ ] out yourself why
don't you try and fight back
i think because this time i'm innocent
and i want the chaos
i think wade was closer i'm pretty sure
wait off and then we vote ethan off
i think i think mark might be other
imposters what could maybe yeah okay i
gotta find ethan and uh
kill him i'm literally just gonna kill
ethan because there's no way that i can
win this round
so i need to find ethan and i need to
kill him i don't care if it's broad
daylight
i don't care what it is um that this is
literally my only purpose
this round is i have to kill ethan
i just want it there he is oh my god
over here
oh my god ethan's dead i found his body
he was murdered did you murder him
he was he was dead when i was there and
found him
he's dead i'm shocked and traumatized
i don't even remember where the location
is so
the details are foggy trauma does weird
things
there was a lot of blood there was a lot
of blood
there's so much blood
oh my goodness i did it man if we get
this this killed him
for revenge because i was try if if i i
almost got the double kill with wade and
him it would have been so clean i had to
finish the job
you know you ruined the fun when we
don't get the eject cover but there was
so much
blood everywhere the walls
it was shown for yourself
no no i need the details it's just like
i felt the
the knife go in and the knife go out and
then the
hot gush of blood were spilling over my
hand and oh and i just hear him go no
no and i whisper in his ear this was for
wade and i know
for some reason i flubbed i didn't
realize you got him i was down with
ethan i was like did
did wade get bob did he and i i didn't i
didn't quite
get it but it was accidental well the
problem was there were three people
because
i was thinking it but then chilled was
also over there so i was like we better
not yeah so then i accidentally locked
the door on myself and i went to unlock
it and actually killed bob
and then ethan walked over and i was
like panicking you accidentally do
all of that those are very good guys
i'm wade do you guys want to change the
levels or do you want to play that yeah
let's do the level we haven't done yet
oh great well good luck good luck
oh what is this what is this uh
where are we okay we're here okay okay
okay okay okay where is
this okay
all right i'm going to the farthest away
point i am
so dead oh whoops i didn't realize this
is what it was
okay all right and this one
okay all right this is going great
very confident very confident
okay there we go uh no
it's all down here well that's not good
what is this what oh
okay this is great great stuff
oh my god this is awful i hate this this
is the worst
what is this what is that that is a
terrible
oh whoa oh oh
i found bob in the lab who was up in
reactor who saw who
i fixed the one right next to wade and
then was running towards the other one
and i couldn't figure out which
direction it was
i kept taking wrong turns to get to
reactor do you have to go through
decontamination yes okay so
laboratory is next to reactor then so
who was up there who
who saw who up there i just got in the
decontamination room so i
like i don't know i didn't get to the
top at all i just opened the door to go
up that way
i know i saw well tesh is dead now but
there was a couple people that did the
o2 ryan we you were up by the top 02
tree uh that's what i meant i did the
top 02 with wade
i saw i think i saw someone do o2 up
north and then and then i was running
off chilled
i didn't want to i was running you were
to go for
the wave you were doing something yeah
ryan was in the top o2 i thought she'll
divert away from o2 when
when second o2 wasn't done and you were
going towards the reactor
yeah if you look at the indicator uh it
looks like it's on the other wall i
didn't know where exactly it was did
anyone see my skip i'm skipping
i saw mark at admin with me and wade
yeah i was down wherever that was
all right thank three friends who died
in vain sorry
[Laughter]
also quit killing bob i'd only do that
okay
this way i have no idea what the problem
is
is it tyler's tyler about to kill me
okay nope so i just gotta go into
decontamination
apparently
this does not bode well
oh okay
okay easy easy
this yes
okay oh we got one more well that's dumb
okay all my tasks are done so was there
a dead body written
okay i was running next to mark and
i came upon a dead body he did not
report it at all i didn't even see a
dead body
and i have a rock solid alibi because
i have not played this level before and
i one of these
was really weird it was the sorting the
crystal bone leaf into three separate
boxes i just did that one we
i've never done that that one's
definitely on the last level
no no that one's different
skull crystal bone and some a leaf that
you put
into four slots this was six items into
three boxes
and there was another one that was like
downloading weather balloon data and it
was like three bars
each one went slower than the other like
i've never seen that before so you're
using the newbie defense
you got that right the the lights were
off
so it was hard to see i actually saw the
report button before i saw the
body that's funny if the imposter can
see
farther i'm not a noob enough to know
that i didn't see a body
okay so here's the deal uh-huh and i'm
i'm left to believe
mark on this one so i definitely think
it's mark if he's doing if he's seeing
new stuff
there's literally no way you can pin it
on me
don't even try to gaslight me it's
chilled that's what it is you literally
can't there's no defense it's ryan
and it's chilling i think ryan's
definitely chilled is now throwing ryan
under the bus
we have to vote ryan down hit the
emergency button
[ __ ] up ryan [ __ ] up ryan you guys
are gonna hate yourself but it's tyler
if it's not ryan it's tyler and chilled
and we've lost anyway
that's possible it's good games
[Laughter]
wait wait wait it's okay we got the
moral
victory we got the moral victory
[Music]
bye